Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burr is time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 25th,
2017 oh it's Christmas
and merry Christmas to you.
Merry Christmas to you and
happy birthday to Jesus.
A merry Christmas or
happy birthday to you.
Ooh.
Oh the lovely Nia.
My lovely daughter both wearing
Christmas pajamas is my first question.
What in God's name are you doing?
Listening to a podcast on Christmas.
My wife is already mad enough
at me for doing one. Hey,
gorgeous. How are you doing? This
is how I woke up in the morning.
I was laying in bed and I felt high.
I felt these little hands,
it's a little hand squeezing my fingers.
So I thought she was just sleeping,
just sorta like squeezing
my hand or whatever.
So I took the pillow off my giant head
and I looked over and she was sitting up
and I looked at her and she just
waved at me. I love the way she waves.
We were joking. My daughter waves
at you from like six inches away.
She waves like she's on a
luxury liner like cruise boat.
And you'll hear a hundred
yards away in the dark.
It's this giant wave like,
hey man,
I'm right here.
You got blueberry all over your face.
Um, anyways, merry
Christmas to everybody. Uh,
you know, I was going to tease everybody,
but what are you doing? You know,
it's funny, this is a tough time
of year to be alone, GI bill.
You really went in deep into your brain
to figure that one out, not only alone.
Then they got all these,
damn,
they got all these damn songs that just
make you feel worse about yourself.
You know, if your life stinks and
you're sitting there going, Oh God,
what have I dealt with my life? I
pushed everybody away. I'm all alone.
And as you're thinking that,
oh,
you hear in the background as you walk
in through the liquor stores, just,
it's the most wonderful time of the year.
They got to update that, right?
Unless you're divorced Ed,
you can't see your kids because
your wife is a cod ex wife. Sorry.
It's a boast.
Wonderful full time.
Um, I do actually, you know, I am
envious. This is when, you know,
if you don't even care that you're
alone today, you are a true loner.
You are a first ballot hall
of fame or what do all the,
all the cliches, you know,
Mount Rushmore.
I met one time,
I f I spent a Thanksgiving alone and uh,
this is how, this is how deep and dark
my life was. I thought it was hilarious.
I was mad. I wasn't sad for any moment
during the day. Thought it was hilarious.
I didn't have any Turkey, any, any
of the fixings, any of that stuff.
And I actually,
uh,
I called up this other comic,
I think it was Ryan Dalton,
one of my friends from Cleveland
and I believe he just came over to my
drab New York apartment and we just sat
there getting shit faced.
You know, I just, I was
in a point in my life,
I was just so excited that I wasn't in
a relationship. So there was no like,
cause at that point I didn't
even know how to be in one.
So the fact that I wasn't in one
and he obviously wasn't either.
We both would have had somewhere to go.
I just remembered,
I think that's why I was so happy because
so many years I was in a relationship
that I just, I dunno, I just
wasn't ready to be in one.
And then I was sitting there going,
Oh God,
I'm meeting their family
and let them Idela.
I gotta get out of the thing rather than
just relaxing and enjoying the moment.
So I was actually in my comfort
zone being all alone. Aw.
What happened? Bill? I'll
put, gives a shit. Um,
so Billy Beantown is
back in Boston and um,
you haven't seen any beans up here,
by the way.
So funny how that nickname just stuck.
I guess at some point they used to
fucking make bake beans, you know,
kind of how they used to go wailing
and, you know, I don't know what else.
Uh,
I don't know what else,
what else should you make buckles for hats
for the pilgrims, but for some reason,
uh, making beans has stuck here.
Now. I don't know if you've,
if you've never been to Boston,
I just, I don't, spoiler alert.
You're not gonna find a lot of beans here.
All right.
I went to the big apple. New York City.
Never saw really any more apples there.
Why did they call it the, this a different
reason for that isn't there? New York,
why do they call it that,
right? It is right there.
Yeah.
Why do they call it the big apple?
All these fucking chicks with the
big assets down there. Apple bottoms.
Is that what it is?
My big apple is a nickname for New York
City was first popularized in the 1920s
by Jay Fitzgerald.
What?
John Jay Fitzgerald. Okay. A sports
writer for New York when it's popular.
Since what the fuck? Why? Why
is it called the Big Apple?
I don't give a fuck
about John Jay Fitzgerald
origin of the name. Oh, somebody's
calling me. I'm not answering that.
Okay. Although the history of the
big apple was once thought a mystery,
a clearer picture of the term history
has emerged due to the work of amateur
etymologist Barry puppet.
Yeah.
And Gerald Cohen, who gives a fuck
about them? A number of false theories.
I don't care about
those. Oh, include, okay,
well actually I like this one.
Yeah.
A theory,
uh,
previously existed including a claim
that the term derived from a woman named
Eve who ran a brothel in the city.
This was subsequently exposed as a hoax.
I love how they figure out that it's
a hoax. How do you figure that out?
Like where would you start?
You know,
especially as they've been calling it
that or that was the lie for all these
years.
How do you go back and fact check it?
New evidence suggests the earliest
known usage of the big apple in a book.
In the book though the
wayfarer in New York,
I mean know to wayfarers sounds like
a fat person that eats crackers.
Well, it's wafers. Those
are cookies. What is,
it is a literally a
whole fucking page here
in which added another Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
William safely considered in this coinage.
But where is the answer?
Kansas is apt to see in New York City,
a greedy city.
It's inclined to think that the big apple
gets a disproportionate share of the
national SAP. Oh, so
that line from the book,
Kansas is apt to see in
New York City and in,
in New York are greedy city.
Is it inclines to think that the big
apple gets a disproportionate share of the
National Sapp? I, I, you know,
I,
you know,
I don't feel like I'm any closer to
understanding why it's called that.
What the fuck does that mean?
So the way that's worded,
it seems like they were already
calling it the big apple or you know,
cause if you read like Tom Sawyer and
everything that like, hey, you know,
if you're, if you're whitewashed
my fence, I'll give you an apple.
And they're like, boy, oh boy. You know,
cause they didn't have any snickers bars.
So an apple was like a tree.
It was a treat back then.
So maybe that was their big dessert.
I get the fuck out of people making pies.
That's all women did back then.
They weren't allowed to vote. Right.
They know if they just
sat around making pies
bitching that they weren't out in the
fields behind a fucking team. Oxen,
why do you get to go out there
and smell that auction? Hey Lady,
you want to do this?
It's all yours
fucking sitting here and kneading dough.
I'd rather do that to be outside
in the elements, but you know,
if that's what you want to
do, by all means. All right.
Speaking of apples, you
guys, friend, you guys, uh,
are you guys fans I should say
of the, uh, the band primus?
Well, their drummer, uh, Tim Alexander
has a cider called Herb Sida.
If you'd like to get boozed up,
go to ww dot Herb's cider.com
and check that stuff out.
I actually had a little girl,
I can't actually have a glassy pool of it.
He sent me some,
but I can't have a glass.
He pull of it until I come off the wagon,
which is probably going to be
happen on the day of the Rose Bowl.
It's my 10th rose bowl in a row.
Me and Bart Nick are going to be there.
Maybe we'll have a little bit of
herb cider or whatever. Check it out.
If you're into cider, if you'd like to
get hammered and also be like, yeah,
but dark. I'm also have an apples
herb site or is this thing for you?
I'm going to check out his
website here. Go to the page. Yes.
That's what I want to do.
Please. For the love of God,
for the love of God,
slowly opening,
I should have hotel internet.
I always pay for the extra amount.
Oh, it's got a great label.
I'll tell you right now,
if it's as good as that God damn label,
I'm going to be drinking
some of this stuff.
Yeah,
I love all these musicians now can like
branch out and actually have like other
businesses and stuff
before it's like they had,
they hit songs and then some greedy
bastard would steal from them and now they
got like clothing label,
clothing lines and all of this shit.
This guy's making cider,
you know?
Do you know the smothers
brothers have their own vineyard?
That was like unheard of back in the day.
Maybe John Elway would have a couple of
car dealerships have something like that.
But usually the performers, when we
were done performing, we were screwed.
You know, if we weren't out there
tap dance and we will fuck book.
Can I come up with,
what should I make bill burrs big book
of content in like all the different ways
to say it and I'll go around
the world, you know, find out.
I'll find out the origins of it.
Back to j f Scott Fitzgerald.
Yeah.
You know,
people in a Tupelo,
Mississippi think that the big
con gets more of its share.
Yeah.
Of Deceptive. I'm sorry. Um,
um, anyways, I don't
know what to talk about.
I didn't know why the
fuck I'm doing this today.
You shouldn't even be listened to.
You ought to be ashamed of yourself.
You much shit.
My wife's going to give me,
she was saying he doing the podcast today.
Well I do the podcast.
I go cause it's fucking hilarious.
Then I'm podcasting on Christmas morning.
Is there something funny about that?
Right. We already had Christmas breakfast.
We're going to go to my parents house for
Christmas dinner. I got a window here.
Snowing outside all the way.
The route side is frightful,
but your smile is so delightful.
That's really something that serial killer
would be singing right as you're tied
up in his cabin.
Oh,
the weather outside is frightful,
but your smile is so the ledge
you sit in there all gag on it.
Sorry, I don't know what it
is about Christmas music,
but I always just think creepy shit.
There's something about it.
I think when I was growing up,
just watching it past a certain certain
age and you start to figure out adults a
little more and you just like, you
know what? Nobody's really that happy.
This is all bullshit. This
is all part of the lie, Huh?
Full Christopher. Cringle how
about those patriots? Huh?
How bout those patriots?
How about those buffalo bills?
That's one of the best teams
I've seen them have both games,
even though we kind of kicked her ass
the first time. But I mean, they're, uh,
when they're eight and
six when they came in,
they're looking at their ninth when
they might be 907 this year. You know,
when I say I say good for them,
good for them.
I don't know who the
hell if safety was it.
That quarterback who jumped that route
timed it perfectly and got a very rare
interception.
Pick six off a Tom Brady,
but you knew we were going to win.
Anytime Tom Brady throws a pick six weeks,
that's when he's, he gets pissed.
All you did was piss him off.
He's going to come back and
just blow the game wide open.
Nobody knows that better than people
down in Atlanta. Merry Christmas.
Atlanta Falcon fence.
I love you guys so much.
I brought up the biggest choke
in Superbowl history. Once
again, I apologize. Okay.
And Happy Hanukkah too. If you're
a Jewish fan, happy Kwanzaa.
If you're an African American fan and,
uh,
I don't know what the transgendered
people celebrate these days,
but whatever that thing
is, I'm, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make sure I know what that is
so I don't cause a big dust up on social
media. Um, I'll watch the Bruins when,
and I went to the Celtics and
they want against the bulls.
We've got a great young team and a buddy
of mine has tickets right behind. Ah,
my Gorman and Tommy Heinsohn.
So for one quarter I got
to sit down there and uh,
you know, heights, it's like six,
seven see sitting behind him,
he can barely see the damn game.
Lisa transition game when
they're bringing it up the court.
But I have to tell you, it was,
um, back in the day I always,
I kind of wanted to be a sports
broadcaster. So actually watching them,
they both had a guy on
either side. Like, you know,
when they sit there and be like,
he's got 16 points. It's like,
how the hell do they know that?
It's like as they were scoring points,
whoever's scores,
their whole line of stats,
the player would light up and the
points is all the way to the right.
I believed and I'm,
I was just kinda watching how
they were able to do that.
I mean just there's so much stuff you
got to know what's going on and then
understand like the
importance of what's going on.
Like when you watch a game at home,
you know what's going on,
you're into the flow of the game and then
you talking about the next day at work
and so much of that is because of
what the announcers are telling you.
This is a big play here.
They got to convert this third
down and then they don't owe.
That was devastating.
You got to work like,
no, it was a pretty poor.
The cable you do need you to convert
that Toronto, you don't even know.
I realize you just, you just saying
what the fuck they already said. What's,
when you go to the game by
yourself, you know, there's so much,
there's just so much crap going on.
Good Lord.
Every time there's a stoppage of play.
They had this, this, this group of kids,
little funk. They always have these
kids dancing. Okay, that's fine.
I hate it. I hate killing kids
in show business that young.
It's like you should be up building a
goddamn snowman going out doing this whole
dance routine.
How long did you work on that?
Just picture some mean fucking teacher.
We're not leaving till we get
it right from the top five, six,
seven, eight. Right. They have that.
They got fucking Santa Claus coming out,
break dance and it on his head and it
really kills like feeling like you're at
the game.
Like I was heckling the bull's coach
guy name was Fred something or other,
you know we were sitting down in loans
so he kept standing up and those damn
coaches, they like block your
view. So I'm going on a Friday,
grabbed some fire,
drag some pine that Fredrik?
Yeah.
Hey Freddy. You know you could coach
sitting down. All right. What do,
what does hands on your hip beads?
No Defense
Fred just doing that shit and everybody
was like looking around, you know,
my father in law was getting
embarrassed. I'm like, Mike, dude,
this is what people used to do.
This is what you say.
This was let's say there
was also people laughing.
That's what used to happen when
there was a stoppage of play.
Fans would yell out what they thought
should have been going on. Yeah.
Know, hey day, once you let him
get to the fucking elbow again,
how many times you've got to hit that
shot on you. And everybody would laugh.
Now the second that damn thinks up,
are you ready?
Gay, Gay, gay, gay, gay, gay,
gay, gay and all these fucking
kids run out on the court.
It's like I'm trying to get drunk
and yell at people that I don't know.
Why are you bringing kids into this?
Um,
but I was stone sober.
Um, anyway, so we want,
but either way the game was great and um,
just seeing the Celtics live,
how young they are.
Even our bench is great.
Yeah.
I keep forgetting the name. What's
the name of our, our sort of center,
the big white guy.
He looks like a yoga instructor
that moonlights as a lumberjack.
You know, he's got the man
bun going. See, you know,
we spiritually is progressive and then
he's got the giant beard so he can't tell.
Is this guy like a hipster?
Is He from the Pacific northwest?
And he in his grandfather used to get
on either end of an accident. Oh Wow.
Oh Wow. Ready to take a fucking tree down.
Whatever the hell they did out there.
Um,
what's his face?
Rosier had this much to fucking dunk
towards the end of the game. Explosive.
Something you never used
to see on the Celtics.
We used to be a bunch of slow white guys.
Even our black guys was slow just
hanging out with the white guys.
They didn't have to try,
try as hard in practice.
And then they sort of became like a,
you know, almost not black anymore.
They were like mixed.
They had a little bit too much white them.
Next thing you know, they had developed
an outside shot. This is all true.
This is why we had a tough time
keeping up with the showtime Lakers.
Too many whites. All right.
I'm just making up shit.
I don't have any reads this
week. You know, I dunno.
I guess when you, when you
piss off Sherry's berries,
then the dominoes just fall.
Now I think people just like
no one's going to be listening,
nor is anybody can be podcasting on
fucking Christmas. You know what?
Everybody thought that and here you
are listening. You know else knew it.
Tim Alexander from Primus,
so that's my only read it this week.
Why don't you sit down, ignore your family
and drink at nice jug of herb cider.
If you'd like to drink some,
go to
www.herbcider.comherbscider.com.
Um, all right,
my wife's going to kill me in a pod.
There's going to be a shorter podcast.
Unusual. All right, let's
give me an a bridge. First,
kids want to open their gifts here.
All right, let's get to the reeds here.
Comedy bubble.
Hey Billy.
Hey Billy burrata toes.
I liked that one.
I'm speaking of Berata and went to
the north end and I have lovely,
lovely Italian meal and a
little Berata and the appetizer.
That was unbelievable. Then I went down
to a cigar bar, the bunch of relatives,
we smoked a couple.
This is fucking asshole.
I always go to that cigar
bar in the north end.
Okay.
And I always forget the name of
it. It's an, it's an Italian name.
Fuck is the name of it's cigars
is the last thing. Let's see.
Cigar Bar North and Boston.
What does it stands at?
Delsa Gary.
Yeah.
Oh, DC Gari. Um,
where they were having a great frigging
time and for some reason they have this
bell,
they're like,
you'd ring between rounds and
this fucking jerk off Boston guy.
He's got this hammer and he keeps hitting
the bell and I'm watching this dude in
this bowl in short, coming over, you know,
with the Boston angry face with
his eyebrows up going, hey buddy,
knock it off. Stop ringing the bell.
Right. And the kid keeps ringing the bell.
I'm like, fuck, what the
fuck is with this kid?
And then I peeked over and I saw you had
like the earring in his ear. I'm like,
oh, that guy. Oh, that guy,
he's going to be that guy.
And the guy just would not stop ringing
the belt by appreciated the fact that
the fucking, the one dude was
trying to get them to stop.
But then the other dude there with
the man bun in the fucking beard kept
laughing. They get it was funny. And I was
like, right there. There you go. That's,
there's the generation gap right there.
The millennial kid thinks it's funny.
The other dude who was also kind of
young but probably at an angry dad,
did not think it was funny. So I
was rooting for him. But either way,
I had a great time and
I want to thank them.
They always treat me great when I go in
there. Um, cigars wasn't were amazing. Um,
that's sort of a tradition.
I always end up there at least one night,
if not seven. All right. Comedy
bubble. Hey Billy burrata toes,
huge fan from Pakistan.
Saw you at the Atlanta punchline of
few months ago and it was amazing.
Thank you very much.
Recently I've noticed some established
comedians on social media shitting on
open makers in newer comedians
for trying their luck at comedy.
Yeah,
that's not nobody funny is doing that.
I get that there are a lot of comedians
around now in comedy in general is very
trendy, especially with Netflix.
Releasing is special every week this year.
But is it fair to say there
is a comedy bubble now?
Is it even worth it for an aspiring or
up and coming comic to try their hand at
it? Wanted to get your
take on this uh, love you.
Stand up the podcast and episode family.
Thanks and go love yourself.
Um, and that for the holidays.
Great. Great. Great question.
All right.
Um,
standup comedy is always
going through some sort of a
opera down as, as any business. You
know what I mean? Look at the NBA.
The NBA was through the roof,
popular, right through the Jordan era.
Then it made a dip and now
it's starting to come back.
And then Lebron and all those guys, it
brings it back up and down, up and down.
NFL is on a little dip here. Tom
Brady, towards the end of his career,
Peyton Manning's gone. Andrew
lugs heard Aaron. Roger gets hurt,
parity and all that. They got to figure
it out. There's always ups and downs,
but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't go after your dream.
I started comedy March 2nd,
1992 after the big eighties bubble
bursts. And there was a bunch of, uh,
not a bunch, but there was a
number of older comics. Um,
when I started out that
tried to discourage me from
starting none of the funny
ones. And they go, look at this. So this
Kras, this places like half full. Yeah.
Two years ago there'd be a line
around the block, you know,
and they used to get me all
depressed in that type of stuff. Um,
any established comedian that shits on
an open miker and tries to discourage
them is not even worth your
time. Like, how pathetic is that?
What else are you going to do?
You're going to make fun of a
toddler learning how to walk.
She just give her a bath. Oh. Um,
all right.
I need to get off because she's getting
more annoyed by the second that I'm out
here. What? It was my Christmas
too. I enjoy podcasting. Um, yeah,
those people are not even worth your time.
And is there a comedy bubble
right now? Uh, yeah, absolutely.
You put out 50 to one network,
put out 52 hour long specials in a year.
You do. You can't do that. It stops
being special. It becomes like a, like a,
like a fucking log jam and you know,
you need to have space. It has
to breathe. It's like a song.
You can't have everybody doing
a tap on solo at the same time.
It just becomes noise. Um, but you know,
this is the, uh, I think it's gone
up twice since I've been doing it.
You know, it, it dip, dip, dip,
dip, dip, bit, bit, bit, bit,
bit baby, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom. All in the beginning of my
first eight years of my career.
And then after nine 11, it went up,
it went up, it went up, it went up,
and then it started to come
back down again. And then, uh,
the ability for Comedians to shoot
their own specials and sell them,
made it go up, up, up, up, up, up, up,
up, up. And I would think that the,
the peak of this, it's like a
housing bubble with standup specials.
That one network has 52 of them.
But the thing about Netflix
is it's also global.
Yeah.
So it's not like,
mmm,
they're just doing it for
the United States, you know,
which would be insane if you
just did that for one country.
It's for everybody around the world.
So maybe that levels it out. I mean,
from what I've heard from Netflix,
they're gonna try to have
more of an international
flavor next year when they do
it. I have no idea. I have no
idea. But I don't see that's,
it's beyond my control.
I'm not the one who decides,
nor should I be how much so many
specials get put out there or whatever.
But it's not going to discourage me
from trying to write my best hour. Yeah.
MMM.
But it's definitely making me think about
how to release and when to release my
next one.
MMM.
Yeah. I hope I answered your question,
but do it. If you want to do stand up,
but you got to do it. It's the greatest
fucking job ever. If you're good at it.
If not, it's uh, you know, I'll tell
you it's a rough one. Okay. But yeah,
don't ever listen to any fucking ass.
Don't listen. Anybody in general,
whatever business you're in,
somebody's discourages you.
What kind of an asshole does that?
Hey, I want to do this. Ah, yeah.
I don't know why you want to do that bad.
I mean,
unless you're talking about trying
heroin, you know, other than that,
I think I want to start my own business
book. Probably going to go under.
It's actually,
I will tell you,
it's actually good that
somebody is doing that to you,
that you're getting that this early in
this business because the key to success
is tuning people out,
okay?
And,
and being around positive people that say
things that make you feel better about
what you're going after.
Now,
I'm not saying that at some point
you won't have an idea that is,
you know, you need to think about
again. You know what I mean?
So somebody would be like, hey man, you
might want to watch out because of blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. I'm not
saying that a negative response,
it's not even negative
constructive criticism.
There's always gotta be a place for that.
But you can't have people who are just
being negative just because you're going
out and doing something and you'll be
able to tell the difference. All right,
knee, I'm almost done.
No response. All right,
rush, reaction, video a, the
ability, five, four, time.
Love. You Love Nia. Love your freaking
podcast. And I thought you'd love this.
These guys review albums that apparently
listeners ask them to do a video on
Russia's y z.
They do a lot of rap albums,
but I've reviewed metal bands.
Like I can't say that's Sepultura.
It's really fun listening to them react
to the drumming and the guitar changes.
Merry Christmas. You beautiful
bastard. I actually, uh,
I didn't get to see this video until
you, uh, to right before I started this.
And as you can see, tensions are
building with my Christmas here. Um,
I watched a little bit of a, um, I'm
definitely gonna Watch the whole thing.
It was cool to see that they liked it.
I knew that they're going to be like,
what the fuck is this in the beginning,
as I mentioned before,
that's why y z is the,
uh,
the call letters for Toronto
International Airport and,
and y Y,
z is the Morse code.
Uh,
uh,
that at that, that, that,
that, that, that, that they're
playing the Morse code of y,
Y, z. It's one of their, one of them.
And the band was flying a plane and they
heard it and they thought it sounded
cool. So they put it to music. Um,
there you go. That's what that is.
Anyways, so it's funny, I was watching
him listen to this shit going. Yeah.
They haven't dropped into the groove yet,
which basically means it's not in four
yet. Essentially for a lot of people,
if that's all you listen to. All
right, original six nonsense. Hi,
Bill. I want to know what your
thoughts are on the original six.
I call it the original.
Who gives a fuck? Oh,
this sounds like somebody who
doesn't have an original six team.
No other sports hold clubs
up on a pedestal above the
rest of the teams in the
league.
It's like all the other clubs in the NHL
are less than because they weren't from
the beginning as a ducks fan. Now, Jesus,
you're not a ducks fan.
You're a mighty ducks. We,
you're named after a Disney movie.
I get it.
When you can't win enough cups to try and
get some sort of fucking manly vibe on
your team. Um, as a ducks fan, I know
you hate them. I don't hate, I don't,
uh,
I,
I went out and supported them with
those gay uniforms and gay name.
It was always humiliating playing
the wings or Boston in those
eggplant fucked up green colors with
the cartoon duck on their jersey.
Well it made sense. It was
named after a kids movie. Uh,
I think we've earned some respect
for going through the shit you did.
You did your daddy teemu
Salani and had all those guys.
Then angry bastard from uh,
was,
was it from a Vancouver you have
down there the hell's his name,
Ryan or some shit. Um,
cartoon duck on the Jersey.
I think we've earned some respect for
going through that shit. I was like,
it was like wearing a dress
to a biker bar. Every game.
I can't stand every time we
play the leafs or Montreal.
They always mentioned the
original six bullshit. Anyways,
I wanted to know what your take
is on the original six. Um,
well I love sports history,
so I like it.
And even if I didn't have a team
that was in the original six,
I like the expansion six.
Uh,
let's see if I can still name them.
That's the fly is the penguins.
Yeah.
Oh boy. The California Golden
Seals to St Louis Blues.
Yeah.
Nice to be able to rattle this off.
Every team has the Minnesota North Stars
and the Los Angeles kings oof by the
skin of my teeth. I did that. And
then for those, um, who don't know,
the California Golden
Seals moved to Cleveland,
became the Cleveland barons and that
went under and I believe merged or
something with Minnesota. I can't
remember. I don't remember any.
I used to know all that shit. Um, I
like the original six. I wish that, uh,
more leagues would talk
about that type of stuff.
MMM.
You know, like the NFL and that
type of stuff. I just think,
I think it's interesting,
personally,
I wish the NFL actually acknowledged
NFL titles the way baseball,
basketball and hockey all count.
They all count titles to the
beginning of their league. I mean,
the Montreal Canadians,
they like,
they won Stanley cups against the Montreal
maroons in the Stanley Cup was like
the size of a shot glass.
I mean, it is the history.
It probably played the final
game on a fucking pond.
But I mean that is the
history of the league.
What I don't understand what the NFL
is,
how the Green Bay packers are
not the Yankees or the NFL.
There was talking about the
Pittsburgh Steelers because they've,
they've won six Superbowls
but the Pittsburgh Steelers
were around back in the
early days of the NFL and
had an opportunity every
year to win an NFL title and
they didn't. And Green Bay did and
for some reason Green Bay's like, ah,
what are they going to green bay,
you've got four titles so that
what is four or five for? Um,
for some reason they just go,
oh they got for their,
the two behind the Steelers and they have
like 11 NFL titles plus four Superbowl
. So my world, they're up
around 14, 15, whatever it is.
And then you got the
fucking Lakers who count a,
they went some league, the Ba or something
like that and they want a title there.
They count that as an NBA title.
I mean that,
that's one of the biggest
bullshit stats in fucking sports.
How the hell you win an NBA
title before there's an NBA.
The NFL, like look the NHL, like you know,
when the WHL went down or the Ahl,
they've absorbed teams.
Yeah.
As did the NBA. Right. But it was still
the NBA, right. When were they absorbed?
Like the Aba,
you know,
those Aba teams went into the NBA.
The difference with the Lakers
is the NBA didn't even exist.
There was no NBA, it was like
wrestling before it got unified.
There was a little bullshit league here,
a little bullshit league there
and another bullshit league.
And the Lakers were in one
of those bullshit leaks.
And for some reason they get to count
that bullshit league title as an NBA title
because eventually all the leaks combined,
the two leagues or something combined
and it became a stronger league.
And that was an NBA title, not
your Bullshit League one. You know,
that's like counting,
like when they had the AFL,
like the San Diego chargers
claiming that they,
they won like a fucking Superbowl
is some shit because they,
they want to an AFL title one. Yeah.
Um, but whatever, that's what it is.
It's very la to pad your
fucking resume. So, um,
for some reason nobody calls him on it.
Um, so I love, I love the original six.
Um, I think it's cool.
And it's also, you know,
there were more teams then the depression
hit and then they went down to six
teams.
That was the deal.
According to Barton at the Pittsburgh
penguins were around some team from
Pittsburgh and they had black and gold,
cause the Bruins always said the penguins
took their colors. Um, and he goes, no,
we had that in the 20s, or the penguin
steady so knows a different team.
It's like,
all right,
well then you went belly up and at which
point you forfeit the colors and then
the Bruins gone to back.
You don't get to come back and be like,
oh well we can forever.
You don't.
They were already taking your best. It's
a great organization though. All right.
My daughter's boyfriend is
a loop. Oh boy. Dear Billy,
the kid first I want to say that I
loved the first two episodes of f is for
family and I can't wait. Oh,
the first two seasons, sorry.
And I can't wait for season three.
Thank you.
I don't like my daughter's boyfriend.
I like how this guy gets right to it
and I want to make or break up with him.
Let me tell you about my girl.
She's 28 years old. She has a job.
She's living in an
apartment with this guy.
The problem is is that she pays for
everything because he's air quote between
jobs and also sometimes she calls me to
fix some stuff for her and when I get
there I find this asked just playing
video games or watching a movie.
Oh my God.
He doesn't even put on a show for when
is the father of his girlfriend shows up.
Yeah, this guy's a bum.
He doesn't do shit.
I really don't understand
why she's still with them.
My greatest fear is if she marries,
she marries that guy.
Can you please give me your opinion
as a father? Oh my God, dude,
I'm brand new to this. You're like
a grizzled vet with a 28 year old.
I got an 11 month old.
I'm going to give you advice.
Can you please give me your opinion as a
father on how to deal with this problem?
Should I tell her to break up with them
or should I just keep my mouth shut?
And I would also love to hear what the
lovely Nia has to say about that sits
about my situation. Thank you. And keep
up the good work. Well, unfortunately,
she's a little pissed at me right now.
So, uh, I only got one more question here.
Um,
I, I think I probably would have
given him shit when I went over there.
I would've just been like,
really?
You're just going to sit there playing
video games while the father of your
girlfriend comes over to this apartment?
What she's paying for everything
and you don't even have a job.
You just going to sit there and
play video games. Who raised you?
I probably, you know, Nah,
I'm not the smartest guy and I
also fly off the handle a lot. Uh,
I would have said something along those
lines and then if he mentioned it to
her, I just say, listen,
I probably shouldn't have said that. I
love you. I want the best for you and
you know, it, it just as
your dad at bothers me that
you're paying for everything.
And then I came over to the
fixed stuff in this guy.
Couldn't even stop playing video
games. Um, you know something.
Don't say anything because then you look
like the asshole. That was bad advice.
All right. Swing and a miss. Strike
one. I would say that to her.
Just say, listen, I'm going to just
going to say this and just say this.
I'm just going to say this one time.
I have to get this off my chest as your
dad because I love you and I want the
best for you.
Okay?
I understand that the person you're with
right now is between jobs and really
try to
fight the urge to do the giant air
quotes between jobs and just say,
listen, okay, I understand that you know,
people have ups and downs in life,
but
it was just kind of a red flag to me
that I went over to your apartment where
you're paying everything, where
there's a man there. All right?
And he sees the father of the woman
that he's dating come walking in to fix
something that he's not fixing.
He didn't even help me.
He continued to play video games. I'm
just saying, I'm a little concerned
about the overall drive
of the man in your life.
And as men, we can't give
you children. All right.
What we do is provide. Okay. So,
uh,
he just looked like a giant 12 year
old to me. Don't say that last part,
but just say, I'm just a little concerned.
Are you, do you share those concerns?
And if she says no, just say fair
enough. Maybe I caught him on a bad day,
but just as you father,
I felt like I had to say something.
If you're okay with them, then I'm okay
with them. And then you, then you go,
cause now you put it out there.
All right.
But if you come at her and you just
say, listen, you need to dump this guy,
this guy's a Bombay guys, eyes judge Joe,
then she's going to get a backup and br,
you know, and it'll become actually more
romantic to her that she's, you know,
it's us against the world. Baby. Did you
hear what I said? The kids can be like,
wow, oh, sorry. Showing to
get to level seven. Uh, that's
the way I would handle it.
And then after that you just got to wash
your face. Oh God. That's difficult.
You got to wash your hands of it.
Um,
I dunno if I could do that.
I,
I mean I would just start, uh, at
some point if she stayed with them,
I would just start openly teasing of
cool.
Hey, what do you say that
they're, they're couch face, huh?
Yeah,
whatever his name is.
Mike. Hey Mike. What's,
what's your favorite couch to sit on
when you're not looking for a job?
You know? Hey Mike, Watch. What's your
favorite? What's your favorite movie? No,
let me guess. Peter Pan, right
when you get to be 12 years old.
For the rest of your fucking life.
Um,
that's what I would just, I would
roast him. No, it rose some.
You're so progressive, you know. Hey
Mike, what do you want 41 for? Uh,
what do you want for Christmas? You
want an apron? Oh, that's right.
You don't even cook.
How about one of those inflatable donut
thinks that truckers where when they sit
on their ass all day getting
hemorrhoids, um, you want to stand up,
desk to play your video games on? I
would just, I, yeah, maybe do that.
I would just start roasting him.
Alright. Bulletproof glass. Dear Billy,
bullet head, uh, writing to you
from the great city of Philadelphia.
A brief background. I am Korean. Oh Dude.
I was just watching a great
movie last night on Netflix.
I'm home of 52 standup specials this
year, including one from me, um,
called, uh, I think it was
called Big Bang. It was called.
It was by the guy just movie starts
in his wife's just like, yeah,
I'm fucking out of here. He's a really
nice guy. And he never breaks the rules.
And you just sort of snaps,
uh,
was watching the beginning of it a
really good acting shot really well.
MMM. I'm going to start what
I'm trying to fuck with my, uh,
my main page here.
You know,
I'd like more shit on music and I
would like a wider variety of music of,
of uh,
movies rather than just the American
bullshit that I already know is out there.
And it probably already saw
what is killing me is, uh,
that Ryan Gosling movie and
the dude from fucking, um,
the gladiator and 20 odd foot
of grunt lead singer there.
What the fuck's his name? The guy threw
the phone at the person downstairs,
which is one of my favorite stories ever.
He shouldn't have done it,
but I just can't imagine the satisfaction.
You're not helping me with the phone.
I'm not going to bring the device.
You're not helping me with it.
I'm going to throw it at the person that
didn't help me. It's all wrong, but like,
it's so right on so many
levels. Um, Russell Crowe,
the nice guys. It's one of my favorite
fucking comedies of the last few years.
A sort of a modern day, midnight run.
I love it, but it's not on Netflix.
Some hoping it's going to get on
this soon. All right, dear Billy,
bullet head right to you from the
great city of Philadelphia. Philly,
a brief background. I am Korean and
my father owns two convenience stores,
both started by grandfather and
grandmother in the mid Seventies.
God am I that old?
It's your grandparents started businesses
in the 70s and I was alive then.
Wow. Already watching
football and collecting cards,
they worked their asses off to provide for
their family. That's right. Old School.
I love it. And make sure my dad
and brothers had a good life. Uh,
one of the stores is in a very bad part
of town and in the mid eighties while
working, my grandfather was
shot at and rubbed. Oh No.
The Bolo went over his head
and missed his head by inches.
This wasn't the first time
he'd been robbed at gunpoint,
but the first time you've been shot at
this obviously scared the shit out of my
grandmother. And eventually they
installed a bulletproof window.
Since installing it,
they've had zero robberies.
And my grandmother's sleeps a bit better.
My grandfather's 78 looks 55 and still
works four days a week. I love this guy.
Uh, just this week a law passed saying
that bulletproof glass is illegal.
The reason a city council woman said
that it may customers feel uncomfortable
and pass legislation to make them illegal.
What is going on in this country
that has got to be the one fucking
neighborhood does this privileged asshole
live in
for starters,
it's insanity that they can dictate
something based on feelings and emotions
that will have physical
repercussions on the store owners.
Not to mention that if we are taking off,
we're talking about these barriers.
Not to mention that if we're talking
about how these barriers affect emotions,
they certainly keep my
family's emotions in check,
worrying about other working in the store.
The woman who passed the law
is a huge client. Agreed.
I'm not a social justice warrior at all,
but this woman's legislation is racist.
Yeah. This sounds just like I
live in a safe white neighborhood.
I don't like going in being reminded
that people who don't look like me are
being shot. I mean it just, you know,
I just had a long today, it's also,
it's only going to affect the pop,
the mom and Pop Asian and other eminent
grant owned stores and it won't have any
effect on the corporate change who don't
have any family working the counter and
won't feel the financial repercussions
of a robbery. None. The problem is, uh,
she's black and no one has the
balls to call her racist. Oh,
I assumed she was white, so I
guess I'm racist. She is though.
She is though.
My question is,
I don't know how she's racist to you
is should I stand outside city hall,
City Hall?
I said silly hall with the sign
stating she's a racist or just a Twat.
Um,
no,
what I would do is I would try to contact
the local news people cause that's a
great story. And if you still have
the bullet hole and all that stuff,
we get dead. Almost dead.
Grandfather almost got killed.
MMM.
Is this Oprah? I mean, who said
this? This is crazy. She a Huxtable.
Um, is that racist for me to assume
that just because she's black,
that she had some point? Must have
lived in a tough neighborhood. Right.
Is that racist on my end or are there
not enough Huxtable black people rapping.
So my idea of, of what their neighborhoods
along. I mean who knows? I mean this,
this opens a giant candidate worms,
but at the end of the fucking day,
I think that uh,
you should be able to,
I think that that should
be not the decision.
Yeah.
Of the government. That should be the
decision of the person who got shot at,
are you comfortable with rolling the
dice that the next one also won't hit you
in the head?
MMM.
This is what I would do. I would not
take it down. I wouldn't take it down.
Even if they force you to take
it down, I wouldn't, I, that's
I would make a giant stink about it
is what I would do. And I wouldn't,
don't say she's racist. Don't say
she's a twice, don't do any of that.
Just what you want to do is you want
to keep the story about how the,
the bullet missed your grandfather by
inches. And I'm much more comfortable,
your grandmother is now with the
bulletproof glass and just say,
and just you killed the, the, he
killed the other person with kindness.
I respect her opinion and blah,
blah, blah. But we work here.
She does not work in these stores. Um, you
know, I'm sure she does wonderful work.
He just keep doing that.
And um,
and then, uh, I would have
to think that someone in
this State Department or whatever they
are is going to be looking at this story
going,
okay,
now if we take down the bulletproof glass
and God forbid somebody in there and
get shot and killed,
what is the state's going to get sued?
MMM.
I, I would mention that. Just say, listen,
I'm not trying to cause a problem here,
but like if something happens
to anybody working in my store,
because you know, the bulletproof glass
is taken down, then I am going to hold,
you know,
whatever the,
the state of Pennsylvania or the
city of Philadelphia and that woman's
specifically,
I'm going to hold them responsible.
That has gotta be the dumbest
thing I've ever heard of.
Who installs bulletproof glass?
Who does that?
Places where people
get robbed at gunpoint.
Okay. And they still have the balls to
stand there the next day and try and,
you know, so I can walk into,
buy a paper and fucking Kit Kat.
Don't they have the right
to feel comfortable?
I mean, yeah, that's, that's,
that's fucked up.
I gotta tell you as a white person,
I'm actually psyched that that was
finally not somebody white doing that.
Hey, finally it wasn't us. Um, so
that's the way I would go about that.
I'd kill him with kindness and a,
and then just sort of, you know,
vaguely put it out there. Maybe have a
lawyer down there just going like, I,
I can't see how this,
the city of Philadelphia would not be
held accountable if something like this
happens. I mean you, you need to
have some sort of stricter gun laws.
We need to solve a whole bunch of other
problems before you have the hardworking,
honest citizens of this great city being
put into this level of peril because it
upsets one person in their mood that
they're reminded that there are bad people
in the world. Okay. Cause did you
have to remember everybody is either,
there's two things.
There's the way you wish the world is
in the way it really is and you have to
act accordingly. All right. And that's
it. Merry Christmas. Happy New Year.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
And uh,
I hope you guys all have a great Christmas
hung out, but I don't know it was,
Hanukkah is still going right? How
many days are in Hanukkah? I Dunno.
I have no idea.
So now on the ninth day of Hanukkah,
my true love gave to me a Kwanzaa.
Whenever that is,
I don't pretend to know. I don't
pretend to be informed. Okay.
But I hope all of you enjoy
your day. All right. That's it.
Okay. If he got a gun, leave it at home.
Just go in and buy a fucking candy bar.
Your content. All right. I'll
see. I'll see you on Thursday.